[Music]
ten years ago today
the day everything changed the banks
were bailed out
the financial system flirted with
oblivion this country's
unhappiest economic saga began had the
bank stopped being rescued
it would have been unimaginably
desperate the entire system was not
working and was going to collapse
people were visibly scared we were right
on the brink
right on the edge but a decade on we are
still asking the question
have we really recovered why is the
economy
still so weak why are so many people
talking not about regeneration
but about decay nobody can see a
promising future so nobody there planned
for the future too far ahead
austerity it's it's been a huge problem
when i become homeless it
really did open up my eyes so we're
asking whether the past decade should
really be thought of as britain's great
depression
for the people in charge 10 years ago
the scars can still be felt today
i suppose the most vivid
memory is the morning of the 8th of
october 10 years ago when
i took a call from the then chairman of
rbs the bank
was hemorrhaging money it was a run on
it shares have been suspended in the
stock exchange
and he said what are you going to do
about it and i said how long can you
last
and there's a pause and he said we're
going to run out of money in the
afternoon
if people worry and try and withdraw
lots of cash can you
fulfill them quickly enough also
security issues around if people are
going to take
bundles of cash around there was a lot
of talk about there's going to be
a great depression like the early
1930s i knew there wasn't going to be
because i knew that we knew what not to
do
and what to do when people say that our
politicians our then prime minister and
finance minister stepped into the breach
and
avoided a complete disaster i think
that's basically true
but now new analysis from sky news
underlines the scale of that crisis
these lines show you the path of gdp how
the size of the economy changed in a few
famous british recessions from history
the 90s and the 30s
a dip then a recovery but now look at
these lines
the red one is the recent crisis the
blue one is the american great
depression that began with the 1929 wall
street crash
our recent recession was far less deep
or dramatic than the american 1930s
but look at what happened next the u.s
economy bounced back quickly in the
1930s
dipped slightly and then searched again
while britain simply failed to take off
after this crisis
the upshot is that this year a decade on
from the slump britain's cumulative
growth is now
smaller than america's was 10 years
after the great depression it's a
staggering statistic and perhaps that
explains why
even now ten years on some workers feel
the country
has never truly recovered the still
industry suffered a deeper crisis than
most
today veteran still workers feel they're
constantly
fighting for survival just people worry
you don't know where you're going what
you're going to do you don't know if
you've got a job next week
we lost a lot too many 2008 2009 and you
just don't know what's happening
your life's on old well it's been tough
for my family
in the sense that my son lost his job
he was with me when the political shock
um he's come talk my brother-in-law lost
his job
how much money did they actually
pour into the banks to bail the banks
out the
the answer by the way is 133 billion
pounds or more than a trillion by some
measures
the idea was we'd all benefit but try
telling that to these guys
there's nothing there you take that
steelworks away
you've got a ghost town there's just
nothing
there's that many men out to work so
they decide to sell their houses out
prices for yes to probably can't sell
your house because there's nobody up
there
anybody wants to buy it i always
remember in 2008 we started weathering
the storm
and i still believe that was still
weather in the storm
i don't think that we've ever come out
of it we've never signed see no sunshine
so why was it the crisis the banks or
what happened after
the cuts
[Music]
we must pay down this deficit this
emergency budget deals decisively with
our country's record debts
yes it is tough but it is also fair
if you don't know what the deep cause is
you've got to find solutions
that will help whatever the deep course
is the real cost to the united kingdom
is the economic cost of how they handle
the years that
followed and the obvious thing to do
would have been spending on the
infrastructure
they thought they could eliminate the
deficits in a five-year period which i
think is wildly optimistic
austerity cutting government borrowing
arguably the most controversial economic
policy in recent years
but away from the boardrooms and the
statistics what does it actually
feel like on the ground we get loads of
support
um from the local community local
schools
churches kerry runs a homeless charity
in harlow
offering everything from a warm meal to
help with job applications
the government says well listen we've
got through the worst of it things are
getting better now
do you do you recognize that kind of on
the ground
i don't think we're seeing that just yet
right not here
the average number of homeless people
sleeping on the streets on any night in
2010 was six
um we've just reviewed our figures now
and for our last financial year the
average
number of homeless people on any given
night in harlow is 23.
okay wow okay so it's kind of quite an
increase and that's been increasing
year on year on year not only in harlow
but you know across the uk
a challenge in other words which seems
to be getting worse
not better for those who've had to live
out on the streets
it's hard i mean sometimes i was sitting
there it was so cold in my tent
i was sitting there thinking just about
committing a petty crime to get myself
phoned in prison
like to get out of the cold yeah that's
how bad it can get
some people i've known actually people
to actually go ahead and do that
like all this about eradicating it in
2022
it's not gonna happen it really ain't
unless someone
really steps in and starts pumping some
money into this it's not going to happen
when there's always the way i see it
where there's rich people there will
always be poor people
but tough as it is according to rupert
harrison george osborne's chief advisor
and one of the architects of austerity
the pain was unavoidable we can't think
about what happened 10 years ago as a
sort of
sudden event that hit the uk economy
from out of the blue
this was the culmination of a decade at
least in the uk of a
very very unbalanced model of growth
austerity was not a choice it was a
situation the uk found itself in we
found ourselves in 2010
as probably the most vulnerable major
economy in the world
and we had to make some very difficult
choices and they were very very
controversial
the macroeconomic story in the uk has
been a successful one
i think the challenges we face are
longer term and more global
the funny thing is that's not a defense
you hear much in politics at all these
days
[Applause]
indeed the politics forged by the crisis
are very different
to what came before what you've seen is
a growth of populism
it's not confined to this country in
brexit it's you know it's right across
the globe
from the election of donald trump and
then the
protectionism that we have here the
brexit vote in britain
populism anti-immigrant feeling around
europe the last few years
i've really felt that i actually want to
make some kind of change
and um and i want to make a change here
in harley
campaigners from momentum the left-wing
group so influential in the labour party
believe the past decade has proven the
need for change
campaigners like laura we've seen the
rich get richer as the poor get poorer
definitely since the recession 10 years
ago i don't think we're out of the
recession
certainly it still feels like we're in
the recession in harley there's no
affordable housing
and a lot of the manufacturing is has
gone offshore
um and i think that actually that's one
of the labour party's policies is to
bring back manufacturing to the uk
i hope you don't mind me saying this
some of that sounds a bit like the kind
of message that donald trump has
[Laughter]
the intriguing thing is these kinds of
concerns about the role of capitalism
aren't just to be found amongst
left-wing activists but also in the
highest echelons of the establishment
the economy the capitalist system is not
delivering for ordinary people
in the way it seemed to be doing
before 2007 and that's the crisis which
i think is still
unresolved i think people are
legitimately angry
about something that's gone deeply wrong
with capitalism
we have a whole load of people who in
2018 have real wages which are
below where they were in 2007 in the
case of america some of them
below where they were back in the 1980s
and blaming everything on austerity
isn't quite fair what if there's
something else going on
what if the financial crisis was simply
the moment we realized there was a
deeper problem in the economy quite
simply
we're not productive enough we're
fundamentally building products that
will go to milking cows
to packaging crisps to cutting metal to
putting a conformal coating onto a
mobile phone to make it waterproof
tony cage runs a high-tech manufacturing
firm in the midlands
as with so many others he still bears
the scars from a decade ago
it was an incredibly fraught period
never before certainly in our industry
had we seen such a
you know a global economic meltdown it
wasn't just a recession in one industry
it was far more than that i mean to put
it into context in the space of four
weeks
we saw a 70 reduction in orders from our
customers
four weeks in four weeks 70 reduction a
lot of manufacturing companies that were
you know really good manufacturing
businesses 10 years ago
and now they're the site of a
supermarket a petrol station or a
housing estate
because they didn't do the right things
they did all the wrong things they
didn't invest
and ultimately they couldn't compete and
they closed in other words was the
crisis
just another excuse for businesses not
to invest in their future
it's a concern for uk manufacturing in
general because
you know we know all of us work in a
global economy and if they're not
investing in automation not doing the
right things
will you be there in five years the
great depression is
rightly remembered as one of the worst
catastrophes in economic history
so whether you blame the bank's
austerity or weak productivity
is it really fair to compare britain's
past decade with that
the last 10 years have been grim for all
of our
economies some grimmer for some than for
others but but thank god we did not
revisit the great depression
we didn't have you know a third of the
entire banking system just
collapsing and defaulting that's what
happened in america
in 1929 and that's what happens
when you simply say i'm not going to
spend any public money on rescuing a
banking system just let it
let it fall we avoided the banking
system collapsing
but then of course the bigger problem
actually if people say what's wrong
today
is the economic crisis that's flowed out
of the financial crisis
but what if after 10 years of struggle
it's now
time to celebrate what if the cuts
are finally about to come to an end
after the financial crash
people need to know that the austerity
it led to is over
and that their hard work has paid
off
well we'll see but while we may not have
faced the extremes of destitution
america faced in the 30s it's clear that
britain's
very different type of depression is not
quite over yet